hey I'm Mike Epps and I'm going
undercover on the Internet
this is actually me looking at
disability is not good
Wikipedia at first on screen the parents
came and Vin Diesel's directorial debut
strays in 1997 yeah that was my first
time on camera
in 1997 I walked up on a movie set and
Vin Diesel put me in his movie he didn't
give me [ __ ] man you're rich now give me
a little money for that movie you did
you made me work hard on her
IMDB appeared in Alicia Keys video how
come you don't call me anymore as Keys
boyfriend
oh man that video was so long ago yeah
I'll never Alicia Keys calling me asking
me she's like oh man cool comedians I
want you to be in this video I was like
oh yeah am I gonna get to fly she's be
look cool she she's like no you're gonna
get hit by a bus I was like oh come on
with it I'll get hit by bus for Alicia
Keys
Quorra why does my caps hit the mic
after each joke it became a habit
actually in my head and my thought
process it feels like every time I hit a
punchline on the joke I'm hitting it on
the nail so when they laughed at the
joke in my mind I'm a carpenter putting
the last nail in the wood I have a setup
punchline setup I got the nail in my
mouth and when I hit the punchline in my
head how can my guests improve as a
stand-up kind of damn question is that
I've been doing this [ __ ] for 25 years
I'm like yes I do comedy I've been doing
comedy for 25 years how can I improve
how can I keep going is the question
I've always wanted to be a guy who
stalked gas station sandwiches and gas
stations they have some of the coolest
jobs they just pull up your gas stations
put these cold air sandwiches and
stations and drive off the hubs is cute
yeah I've been eating gas station
sandwiches for a long time I remember I
went to the doctor a long time ago he'd
said what the heat now it's like a gas
station sounds he's like they're gonna
kill you if you keep me in cast at
Twitter he got a lack on votes and 30
mom the Dukes is in there with mr.
Johnny tricking this right here is like
you know when you live in the inner city
and you black you're young black man and
your mom is cute you might get off the
bus one day and come home from school
and see a Cadillac in the front of the
house and you don't know who it is like
one of your mama's friends
your mama's boyfriend you know usually
women when we see a Cadillac in front of
our house we end up getting school
clothes cuz my mother then met some nice
guy who wants to spend a little money on
our school clothes posted top five
Bernie Martin Chapelle my gifts and
Chris Tucker Wow
it's just amazing that I'm somebody's
top five I'm one of the nineties top
fighters that's a good top five right
there was my top five man I gotta say
Bernie I gotta say Martin gotta say
Eddie you got to say Richard Pryor Redd
Foxx boom u2 day.they when's the next
Friday coming out hmm I don't know
that's my ice cube question if I can get
ice cube on the phone again he might
tell me I'm getting old to do Fridays
hmm I thought Waffle House made an
actual waffle with better right in front
of you so how did you steal a box of
waffles my
hmm still I stole some waffle mix I
might have been cracking a joke somebody
took a series about that I really did I
stole some waffle mix it was a joke
replied Twitter which book should I read
next unsuccessful thug by Mike Epps
we're gonna need more wine by Gabrielle
Union or I can't make this up by Kevin
Hart I think all three are good books I
think it depends on where you read in
life
which book could be right if you are
underdog and you didn't graduate from
high school you dropped that one used by
eighty ninth grade never really worked a
drop been in the system a little bit you
got so many kids you just ride through
the hooding wave you might want to read
my book I am DBE eat eat eat eat doesn't
tell you that friends with Steve Harvey
Fat Joe and Snoop Dogg snoop Dogg
probably the closest guy to me I met
snoop on the next Friday uh from here
when I first got there late the first
movie I did snoop came to my premiere
thanks know we always get good advice
from Steve Harvey he's that one uncle
with that big chilly willy mustache that
you want to listen to what motivated
Mike gets to become a stand-up comedian
I figured out I'm like why am I getting
in trouble
and why am I not focusing school why am
I not good at working jobs because I was
playing the whole time I was like damn
you play too much so when I figured out
I said hmm so how can you get paid for
playing all the damn time
so I looked in the phone book I looked
up comedy clubs and I found one it was
called crackers comedy club in
Indianapolis and I went and signed up
did a great job
and I've been telling jokes talking [ __ ]
swallowing spit for 30 years now not 30
but 30 that's how I see it in the black
community study that a year on my gifts
and Omar Epps related
no I think we got the same mastered Oh
everybody always asking me about my
guests in omar epps hey man we both
brothers we both in the entertainment
game but I don't think we related I
think we all related I think way down
the line
[Music]
lasted what did my kids think of the
song I'm only everything
Eminem sampled one of my jokes offered
my stand-up specials I've been on the
bunch albums I've been on ice cubes
albums and I think some of these rappers
here are jokes and make songs out of
them and they made a song that I'm on
everything so I got lucky to work with
him and I'm on a song
brennick isn't he supposed to play
Richard Pryor and I buy up whatever
happen to that yeah whatever happened to
it I'm still wondering what happened to
it it was one of them projects that was
uh it was under the one of the
Weinsteins it was one of the weinstein
projects so I guess when the movie
stopped at the Weinstein Company the
Richard Pryor movie stop I think I'm a
modern-day Richard Pryor
I think the kids look at me like
something like that not it's quite good
but a little rendition okay
Instagram Oh picture with them egos they
ask me on my playing chest right here no
I'm not playing chess took a picture
with the migos I just did a video with
him like a movie video I'm playing a big
shot always cool to hang around with
young ganas yeah I love amigos what was
you going through in your head in this
moment I was trying to let that poop
pass I pulled it on this picture and
sometime when you poop you got a it's a
look on your face when you waiting on it
to pass kind of like a clown you know
how it rain and the cloud come past
that's how you got to do with a poop cuz
poops are silent and deadly sometimes
you don't see them but you could smell
[Laughter]
yeah gas-station Salas has had four
roles in which this name is Reggie I can
only remember - all about the Benjamins
and I want to say bait with Jamie Foxx
more retic whoo this is a picture of my
57 Chevy right there classic all right
once and for all what does he say is
them tense I'm tense
it sounds like tense but teens what the
word really makes sense 57 Chevy oh gee
with that big SLS engine in it tends
like the number 10 Instagram again hey
Mike do you still get into fights with
the Joker brothers yeah I just chased
one I'm earlier did that knocks the
Joker brothers those are like the guys
who was on next Friday the Mexican guys
yeah I really do see the Joker brothers
in real life when you live in LA go to
the East LA and real Joker brothers how
was my gift selected as a Super Bowl
what's wrong with me how how was I
selected they was having a Super Bowl in
my hometown Indianapolis they had to let
somebody like me ambassador nothing they
gave me free tickets I have got a bunch
of super bowl-like water bottles it was
a bunch of [ __ ] they lied ambassador
and I tried to use it everywhere I went
I was like I'm ambassadors like the hell
is doing best
they said they should have gave you some
laminates with ambassador honor - some
are bad just some they just said it it
didn't work my mother said you are a
bastard but not an ambassador that's it
I'm signing off the internet
holla